quando si Immagina di dare vita a una
famiglia si immagina un percorso quanto
più la realtà si è discosta da questo
percorso tanto più la sfida può
diventare avvincente Questo è quello che
è successo a due giovani sposini qualche
anno fa quando si ritrovarono a
battezzare il loro primo figlio in
un'incubatrice perché è nato prematuro e
perché è troppo fragile e non sapendo se
avesse potuto superare la notte o meno
hanno deciso di battezzarlo in
incubatrice a dare il nome di loro due e
siccome i due sposini si chiamavano
Pietro Luisa quel bambino oggi si chiama
Pierluigi
loro in seguito a un evento un po'
particolare perché il bambino è stato
trasferito di reparto un trasferimento
un po' avventato da parte del personale
senza prendere le dovute cautele quel
bambino in seguito a una mancanza di
ossigeno per un tempo troppo prolungato
riportato una lesione cerebrale che ha
generato quella che è una condizione che
si chiama tetraparesi spastica e a cui
viene associato un grave deficit sia
motorio che cognitivo
questo evento ha ovviamente
cambiato quello che era il percorso che
questi due genitori avevano ipotizzato e
ha condizionato la vita loro del loro
bambino e del figlio che hanno deciso di
avere quattro anni dopo che in questo
momento sul palco sta parlando con voi
Io ho avuto un'infanzia un po'
particolare perché a dispetto dei miei
coetanei non andavo all'asilo la scuola
materna ma andavo nella palestra di
fisioterapia dove mio fratello e i suoi
amici speciali imparavano a camminare
imparavano a superare le sfide che la
vita gli avrebbe posto davanti io mi
divertivo tantissimo e notavo una cosa
molto particolare pure essendo piccolo
che ogni volta che le stupende
fisioterapiste che aiutavano questi
bambini a cambiare posizione mettersi in
piedi quindi a cambiare la loro postura
riuscivano nell'intento sul volto di
questi bambini spuntava un sorriso
incredibile È una smorfia che vi posso
assicurare è quella di Tardelli i
mondiali di spagna dell'82 non era un
granché quando viene chiamato per
parlare un Ted è stato facile trovare
l'argomento perché sono andato a
ripescare quei ricordi e ho notato come
anche la comunità scientifica erano
andati in una direzione e ieri sera
occupata di particolari studi per cui
hanno iniziato a investigare come il
placebo cioè lo studio del contesto
questo biopsicosociale di un soggetto
poteva avere un'interazione con i
farmaci andando avanti in questo ambito
si sono resi conto che c'erano delle
particolarità esattamente uno studio
dimostrato come un soggetto sottoposto a
una somministrazione inconsapevole Cioè
non sapeva che mi veniva somministrato
uno dei quattro antidolorifici più
potenti al mondo non manifestava nessun
miglioramento della sintomatologia
quando però alla somministrazione del
farmaco veniva associato un atto
terapeutico ovvero il personale
sanitario spiegava cosa stavano per
iniettare che effetto avrebbe avuto in
quale tempistica i soggetti dimostravano
subito un miglioramento della
sintomatologia questo per dimostrare che
le suggestioni verbali positive
esaltavano e questo l'hanno notato molto
di recente quelle che sono le attività
neuronali e quelle che sono le
interazioni col farmaco producendo delle
sostanze che migliorano quella che era
la captazione del farmaco stesso
Quindi questa similitudine tra farmaco e
parola è stata sicuramente molto
stimolante per uno come me che non posso
amministrare le farmacie ai propri
pazienti E hanno dimostrato
ulteriormente che sia il linguaggio
letterale che il linguaggio figurato per
il nostro cervello Sono esattamente
identici ma anche il dialogo interno c'è
quello vocina che ci gira nella testa e
che ci accompagna con le nostre critiche
con il Bayern cognitivi che abbiamo e il
dialogo esterno cioè quello che arriva
da fonti esterne che possono essere
amici altre persone ci vanno lo stesso
effetto a livello cerebrale cioè le aree
cerebrali che Si accendevano Non
esattamente lo stesso questa cosa per me
è stata molto importante perché come ho
detto prima io posso lavorare su alcuni
aspetti e non posso lavorare sulla
farmacologia quindi mi sono interessato
a come eventualmente un cambio di
postura potesse facilitare quello che
era il dialogo interno andando avanti
nei miei studi mi sono imbattuto nel
massimo esperto del settore e non
pensate che sia uno scherzo perché ci
arrivavano insieme alla il nostro amico
Snoopy è veramente un esperto se
leggiamo insieme la striscia che c'è
dietro di me e facendola dovuta premessa
che una striscia di un fumetto e quindi
quando si parla di depressione bisogna
sempre camminare e muoversi un po' sulle
uova ci arriveranno dice questo Questa è
la mia posizione da depresso quando si è
depresso la tua posizione è molto
importante la cosa peggiore che puoi
fare è sollevarti guardare verso l'alto
perché in questo caso comincia a
sentirti meglio se vuoi evitare
qualsiasi Gioia quando siete presso devi
stare così
io non so se voi siete convinti o meno
ma siccome sono fisioterapista e passo
la vita a far fare esercizi alle persone
Io vi invito a provare questa cosa qua
adesso quindi vi invito per un attimo a
lasciare quelli che sono gli oggetti che
avete in mano chiudervi con le braccia
in voi stessi abbassare avvicinare
leggermente lo sterno e chiudere il più
possibile in una posizione chiusa
Guardando verso il basso addirittura
chiudendo gli occhi
e poi vi invito a pensare a qualcosa di
positivo di bello in questa posizione
probabilmente
avete un po' di difficoltà
Se invece vi chiedo di andare nella
direzione diametralmente opposta Quindi
vi chiedo di raggiungere la massima
altezza che potete avere da seduti
staccare il mento dallo sterno e aprirvi
e guardare verso l'alto provate adesso
in questa posizione e vedete se riuscite
a pensare a qualcosa di positivo
qualcosa che sappia di vaniglia qualcosa
che vi piace
molto probabilmente al netto del
contesto in cui siamo in questa
posizione viene un pochettino più facile
perché quello che ci ha consegnato la
scienza al giorno d'oggi è quello che ci
ha consegnato Charlie Brown è una
certezza che i pensieri non sono nuvole
i pensieri sono chimica i pensieri sono
dopamina sono serotonina ma può essere
anche il cortisolo che l'ormone dello
stress quindi le suggestioni verbali
negative possono influenzare
negativamente tutto quello che passa per
la nostra testa
Se è vero quello che abbiamo detto sino
adesso e quindi se il cambiamento di
postura agevola il dialogo interno e
quindi agevola la produzione di alcune
sostanze molto probabilmente il cambiare
la postura agevola anche l'autostima che
detta tra di noi potrebbe sembrare una
cosa di poco conto ma se Pensate ai
giovani e gli adolescenti e a tutte le
insicurezze che devono vivere e alle
posizioni che di solito assumono e voi
li beccate in quelle posizioni pensate
Quanto può essere potente questa
informazione cambiare la postura
aprendosi al mondo e relazionale dandoci
e alcune volte può far male ci dà
fastidio crea un aspetto un po'
particolare a questo punto ci si può
chiedere qual è il metodo Allora per
andare incontro a questa postura che ci
fa migliorare i pensieri che ci fa
produrre delle sostanze positive Gli
anglosassoni lo definiscono Col facchine
del make it ovvero vai in quella
posizione in cui Voi essere va in verso
lo stato che voi raggiungere nel tuo
corpo inizierà a produrre tutta una
serie di sostanze che agevoleranno
raggiungere quella posizione nella fase
iniziale questa situazione qua potrebbe
generare un piccolo disagio che prende
il nome di dissonanza cognitiva Ma le
sostanze che producete all'interno del
vostro corpo una volta che avete
guadagnato la nuova postura sicuramente
agevoleranno questo percorso come diceva
Paolo borrodattichello c'è un ormone per
ogni postura e c'è una postura per ogni
emozione quindi Ricordatevi che Decidete
voi quello che deve passare nella vostra
testa e la vostra posizione potrebbe
aiutarvi in questo senso ma se mi
chiedete Qual è lo strumento che noi
abbiamo oggi per gestire questo aspetto
realmente ce l'abbiamo sempre appresso e
della respirazione la respirazione è più
potente metodo per regolare quello che
il nostro stato emozionale molto spesso
quando uno ha agitato gli si dice
Calmati e respira
Il problema non è quello il problema è
che se la respirazione è il controllore
delle nostre emozioni Chi controlla il
controllore Cioè se noi non sappiamo
come respiriamo Come facciamo a
controllare le nostre emozioni
e quindi qui io faccio voi una domanda
Voi sapete respirare
Ok lo prendo come un forse va bene
Adesso ritorniamo su noi stessi
dedichiamo qualche secondo soltanto a
noi stessi Ognuno si prende 5
respirazioni io vi do solo
un'indicazione poggiate con la mano
sinistra sul cuore per convenzione della
sinistra Facciamo che sia questa la mano
destra la appoggiate sulla pancia
dimenticatevi di quelli che ci sono
intorno a voi e fate tre respirazioni in
maniera autonoma Vi chiedo solo di stare
attenti per cercare di capire se la mano
che si muove quella del cuore o quella
della pancia tre respirazioni potete
partire
ok È qui parte il sondaggio quanti hanno
sentito muoversi la mano sinistra
pochissimi quanti hanno sentito muoversi
la mano destra
siete bravissimi siete bravissimi Perché
quella è la respirazione giusta perché è
quello che dovete fare quando volete
cambiare la vostra posizione realmente
quello che voi avete fatto è la
respirazione del coccodrillo il
coccodrillo quando sta cacciando le
proprie prede per non farsi beccare
tiene la gabbia toracica più ferma
possibile e muove solo la donna perché
se muovesse la gabbia toracica la preda
lo vedrebbe scapperebbe via ed è la
respirazione più corretta perché il
primo accenno di respirazione
diaframmatica cioè evitate di usare
tutti i muscoli della parte alta della
gabbia toracica usate diaframma e quindi
in una condizione di stress dove avete
il forte tensione sicuramente questa
cosa vi agevola allentare quella
tensione siccome sono uno che lavora
sulle tensioni vi posso assicurare che
capita molto spesso con la respirazione
voi avete un joystick avete la
possibilità di giostrare su quelle che
il vostro quadro emozionale avete una
sorta di reset delle vostre dei vostri
stati d'animo e quando vi serve Ce
l'avete sempre appresso alla vostra
respirazione
se io dovessi chiedere a voi oggi quante
volte respiriamo in un giorno
Voi siete a conoscenza di queste
informazioni siano
andiamo per sondaggio chi pensa che
respiriamo mille volte al giorno alzi la
mano
Ok 5000 volte al giorno
andiamo al rilancio ci abbiamo 2-5.000
volte al giorno tra 5 e 10.000 volte al
giorno ce n'è qualcuno Ok 10 15 Milan
Quanti ne abbiamo
20.000 ce ne un po' sopra i 20.000
Quanti ne abbiamo benissimo Allora
sappiate che hanno vinto quelli che
hanno detto sopra di 20.000 perché noi
facendo un conteggio normale di una
persona che non fa attività fisica in
maniera intensa quindi stiamo escludendo
la parte dell'allenamento arriva a
respirare fino a 21.600 volte in un
giorno Il problema non è questo il
problema è che molto spesso non sappiamo
come funziona non sappiamo Qual è la
dinamica respiratoria è logico che
escludiamo chi Con la voce ci lavora noi
abbiamo degli schemi di movimento puri
perché le tappe dello sviluppo
psicomotorio dell'essere umano hanno
delle stazioni che vanno rispettate
quando si saltano queste stazioni noi
paghiamo allo sforzo quando ci
ritroviamo ad essere delle persone
adulte tipo ad esempio quando diamo il
girello i nostri bambini per imparare a
camminare prima e stiamo facendo saltare
una tappa ci saranno delle ripercussioni
in futuro il nostro corpo funziona in
una maniera meravigliosa soltanto che
noi per qualunque per colpa della nostra
LinkedIn disimpariamo a respirare
disimpariamo a muoverci E come abbiamo
visto se essendo le cose collegate tra
di loro Probabilmente disimpariamo anche
relazionarci con gli altri non sappiamo
spesso come funziona il nostro corpo
ci viviamo dentro ne abbiamo solo uno
non possiamo versare in concessionaria e
prenderci in un altro ma ignoriamo il
suo funzionamento e non ci appassioniamo
nemmeno a capire come funziona ci sono
molte cose che non sappiamo del nostro
corpo poi ve ne Cito soltanto alcune il
cibo arriva lo stomaco in circa 7
secondi Ok il femore che il nostro della
gamba può essere più duro del cemento
e mediamente il pene dell'uomo è lungo
tre volte il pollice
in questo momento io escluderei della
platea una buona percentuale di persone
che credo sia intorno al 85% che sono
quelli che si hanno guardato il pollice
un 10% che sono quelli più
intellettualmente evoluti in questo
momento si sta chiedendo ma da dove si
misura il pollice
e io da fisioterapista vi posso dire che
l'articolazione è quella tra metacarpo e
la prima falange il 5% che non si
riconosce in queste due statistiche
molto probabilmente ho in mente o in
questo momento sta guardando il pollice
del vicino
se vogliamo togliere i dubbi un altro
punto di riferimento che possiamo
prendere che vale come il pollice e il
naso
adesso lo so che voi volete girare a
guardare il naso del vostro vicino vi do
5 secondi per farlo e poi ritorniamo
sulla presentazione
detto questo siamo arrivati al punto del
perché dobbiamo considerare il mal di
schiena come un'opportunità
perché il mal di schiena rappresenta
questa opportunità perché
voi dovete essere consapevoli di una
cosa che è una patologia che colpisce
almeno una volta nella vita in maniera
grave il 95% della popolazione mondiale
e se non vi ha preso vi prenderà Ed è
inutile che fate gli scongiuri e così
sono statistiche
Noi non dobbiamo preoccuparci di questo
dobbiamo preoccuparci perché questa
problematica cronica rappresenta per noi
un'opportunità perché ci fa riflettere
ci fa riflettere sul fatto che molto
spesso non ci prendiamo tempo per noi ci
fa riflettere Per che è molto spesso
come esseri umani siamo riusciti a far
sì che tutto il nostro ecosistema si
adattasse alle nostre esigenze alle
nostre speculazioni ma allo stesso tempo
non siamo stati in grado pur avendo
fatto Adattare il mondo alle nostre
esigenze di riuscire ad adattare quella
che la nostra postazione di lavoro alle
nostre esigenze quindi ci accontentiamo
di quello che c'è e se consideriamo che
mediamente al giorno d'oggi un uomo
passa circa 15 ore seduto Considerando
gli spostamenti e le ore al lavoro dando
dei carichi molto importanti alle
proprie strutture sta condannando per
forza il suo apparato muscolo
scheletrico avere dei danni che sono
irreversibili
il mal di schiena È un'opportunità
perché ci fa riflettere sul fatto che
negli ultimi anni gli adolescenti che
stanno soffrendo di mal di schiena sono
in costante aumento e sono in costante
aumento perché abbiamo costretto questi
poveri bambini ad adattarsi alle
impostazioni di lavoro degli adulti con
mi mando quelle che sono le nostre moto
di lavorare soltanto che ci
dimentichiamo che loro hanno delle
strutture che non sono le nostre E
perché l'uomo si è adattato a dei
programmi didattici che prevedono che i
bambini di 5-6-7 anni passano tante ore
seduti e non sono pronti per fare questa
cosa qua
l'opportunità che ci dà il mal di
schiena è quella di uno stop e quindi di
permetterci una volta tanto di scendere
dalla ruota del criceto e di prenderci
un po' di tempo per noi come avete fatto
voi stasera vi siete fermati solo per
cinque respirazioni
oggi probabilmente dopo questa
presentazione avete qualche cancello in
più per uscire dalla ruota del criceto
perché molto spesso il forte di girare
ad altissima velocità non riuscite a
vedere il cancelletto io mi hanno
offerto qualcun altro quello che è
importante è che dobbiamo capire che se
vogliamo guidare con l'esempio le future
generazioni dobbiamo dare l'esempio noi
perché loro ci seguono per questo
funziona un po' come sull'aereo in caso
di depressurizzazione della cabina
indossate prima voi la maschera ossigeno
e poi aiutate gli altri ad indossarla Ma
se non guidate voi quell'esempio gli
altri non potranno mai seguirvi non
dimentichiamo quello che abbiamo sentito
oggi in questa presentazione perché è
molto importante cambiamo le parole che
abbiamo usato visto che le parole
funzionano come i farmaci in passato se
vogliamo cambiare il futuro Quindi
magari sostituiamo quel fastidioso
attacca il sedere alla sedia e studia
con un nuovo video e impara
cerchiamo di capire che tutto questo
discorso
sviluppava quello che era il concetto di
adattamento
declinandolo in più fasi Si sono
adattati quei due giovani sposini a un
evento inatteso hanno scommesso sulla
loro idea di famiglia e l'hanno
allargata
e hanno reagito Quindi è una fase di
adattamento attivo e poi c'è il nostro
adattamento alle nostre posizioni di
lavoro che sono passive l'adattarsi è
una prerogativa dell'essere umano spetta
a noi decidere se far andare questa
nella direzione di un qualcosa di attivo
o un qualcosa di passivo Io sono un
fisioterapista fondamentalmente la
fisioterapia è questo e reagire ad un
evento
probabilmente inatteso che ci ha
obbligato ad uno spot a uno stop dietro
una guida e con un modello da seguire e
io vi posso assicurare che una guida
nella vita serve sempre serve a tutti
Non sottovalutate questo aspetto perché
qualunque cosa vogliate fare nella vita
Qualunque sia il percorso la strada che
dovete fare molto lunga e impegnativa ma
siccome non sono bravo con le parole uso
quelle di un gruppo di poeti
contemporanei che si chiama ac/dc loro
dicono It's a long wait to the Top If
You Wanna Rock n' Roll Grazie a tutti
Grazie
[Applauso]